Vorsicht bei der Einfahrt.
Sonntagmorgen Bahnhof Berlin-Ostkreuz. Eigentlich viel zu früh. Am Bahnsteig warten auffällig viele ausflugshungrige Städter. Einige davon wollen auch einmal ein heutiges Ziel. Fürstenberg an der Havel in Brandenburg. Chaosradio Spezial. Der Verstehbahnhof. Ein Hack- und Makespace auf dem Land. Von Daniel Molkenthin. Nach etwa 80 Minuten Fahrt erreiche ich mein Ziel. Mein Weg führt mich durch eine Unterführung vorbei an einem kleinen Café zum Bahnungsvorplatz. Von hier aus starten die meisten meiner Mitreisenden ihren Ausflug in die Natur. Von seinem Grundstück auf der anderen Seite des Platzes wiegt mir mein heutiger Gesprächspartner zu. Er begleitet mich zurück zum Bahnhofsgebäude am Gleis 1. Wir treten ein. In einer geräumigen Werkstatt, voll mit 3D-Druckern, Lasercuttern und allem, was das Meckerherz höher schlagen lässt, setzen wir uns.
Nun bin ich neugierig auf Daniels kleines Rechenzentrum. Das befindet sich in seinem Haus, auf der anderen Seite des Bahnhofsvorplatzes. Wir gehen hin.
Gerade ist es viel lauter als eigentlich, weil wir mit so einer Turbine die Warmenluft aus dem Raum rausziehen und in den Keller verteilen. Das wird so lange, bis draußen zwei Brunnen gebohrt sind, die uns Kaltwasser geben als Wärmewärmepumpe für das Rechenzentrum. Dann ist das im Moment noch etwas improvisiert. Wir haben insgesamt, glaube ich, hier so eine ganz interessante Ästhetik geschaffen. Mit unserem Pyramidenschaumstoff an den Wänden, der auch das Arbeiten hier unten ein bisschen angenehmer macht von der Akustik. So über unsere Oma-Steelampen, die wir hier so überall haben, um unser RZ zu beleuchten, ist das dann so eine ganz gute, glaube ich, ganz wohlige Atmosphäre. Wir halten uns ja hier auch gerne auf. Ich glaube, Teil der ganzen Angelegenheit ist nicht, dass wir hier einen Raum schaffen wollten, in dem man keiner sein will, sondern wir fühlen uns ja auch wohl hier unten. Dann kann man auch hier vor Ort arbeiten und Dinge tun. Das ist ganz gut.
Damit man im Serverraum allerdings vernünftig arbeiten kann, muss das Gebläse weg. Für die Kühlung sorgen künftig die Serverschränke selbst.
Im Endeffekt haben wir in den Türen hinten drin diesen Wärmetauscher, der dann, wenn die quasi von vorne im Rack die Luft angezogen wird, um dann durch den Server durchgeblasen werden, kommt hinten die warme Luft hier raus und die wird dann gleich über diesen Wärmetauscher geblasen und runtergekühlt. Und so haben wir dann in Zukunft eigentlich nur dieses Stück zwischen Ausgang aus dem Servergehäuse bis zur hinteren Tür, in der wirklich warme Luft anfällt. Und das, was dann aus der Tür hinten rauskommt, ist schon wieder auf Raumtemperatur. Und über so einen Wasserkreislauf wird das dann in den Raum nebenan geschafft, das bauen wir jetzt gerade. Da gibt es dann so einen Schichtspeicher, in dem wir dann quasi unten kaltes Wasser haben und oben das warme Wasser. Und dann können wir das warme Wasser oben zum Beispiel für Fußbodenheizung hier im Haus gebrauchen oder irgendwo anders sinnvoll einsetzen. Und gleichzeitig haben wir unten kaltes Wasser, was wir nutzen können, um die Server hier mit dem Vorlauf runter zu kühlen.
Das kleine Rechenzentrum versucht dabei nicht, in den Wettbewerb mit großen Anbietern zu gehen. Allerdings bietet die Region auch für diese Chancen.
Es ist allerdings auch so, dass es ein anderes Grundstück hier um die Ecke gibt und es auch ernsthafte Überlegungen gibt, ob man da nicht noch ein etwas größeres Rechenzentrum baut mit ein paar tausend Quadratmetern. Rechenzentren haben in Berlin ja das gleiche Problem wie die Wohnungen. Das ist einfach teurer Real Estate. Wenn man sich mit einem Betreiber aus Berlin zusammentun würde, um hier gemeinsam was aufzubauen, dann gäbe es hier was, was trotzdem eine ordentliche Anbindung hat, auch über drei oder vier verschiedene Beine, die wir hier gewährleisten könnten. Gleichzeitig wäre es halt wie auch der Wohnraum in der Gegend, in der die Quadratmeter nicht so teuer sind, wie irgendwo in der Stadt.
Auf dem Twitter-Account des Verstehbarenhofs habe ich gesehen, dass sich Flüchtlinge aus Syrien im Verstehbarenhof engagieren. Auch beim Aufbau des Rechenzentrums haben sie geholfen. Daniel erklärt, warum.
Wir sind ja hier auch personell sehr eng verwoben mit unserer Geflüchteteninitiative. Wir hatten bei uns im Haus ja auch sehr viele Geflüchtete, die wir temporär quasi untergebracht haben. Und damit sind wir auch in diese ganze Gemeinschaft total gut vernetzt. Und das ist einfach auch was, was ich glaube, was mir die letzten Jahre einfach auch aufgefallen. Für all die Kinder mit Migrationshintergrund ist das hier nochmal eine ganz andere Relevanz. Weil wir, ähnlich wie bei deutschen bildungsfernen Familien oder bei Familien, denen der Zugang zu Bildung auch aufgrund der Sprachbarriere einfach schwer fällt, wir in der Lage sind, Kompetenzen hier zu vermitteln, die für die Zukunft total relevant sind. Und das ist dann ja entweder eine Zukunft hier in Deutschland, aber genauso für den Fall, dass die irgendwann vielleicht, wenn der Krieg in Syrien vorbei ist, wieder zurück in Syrien, sind das, also ob das jetzt Programmieren ist oder mit uns gemeinsam drüben Fasern im Rechenzentrum gespleißt zu haben, das sind Kompetenzen, die total wichtig sind, wenn man ein Land, das komplett in Schutt und Asche liegt, irgendwie wieder aufbauen möchte. Und wenn man vielleicht eine Perspektive hat, warum solche Kompetenzen wichtig sind und wie man sich damit selber helfen kann, wie man Zugang wieder zu anderem Wissen findet und einfach Lösungen schafft. Und wenn das nur so das algorithmische Denken ist, dass man das einem sicherlich auch dabei helfen kann, ein Land wieder aufzubauen. Wenn man das einfach ein bisschen strukturiert versteht, das strukturierter anzugehen und zu betrachten.
Dass sie etwas aufbauen können, haben die Mitglieder des Verstehbahnhofs eindrucksvoll bewiesen. Doch wie soll es weitergehen?
Also für mich und ich glaube für uns alle hier eigentlich ist das, was wir bisher gemacht haben, nur die Bereitung einer Grundlage gewesen. Also wir haben hier die Werkstatt und in dieser Werkstatt können wir Dinge bauen. Wir können hier nebendran in der Halle eine Veranstaltung machen, in der wir erklären, was wir gebaut haben und warum das eine Rolle spielt. Wir können in der Küche das Catering dazu machen, das wir brauchen. Und wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, wir bauen Umweltsensoren, um die Feinstaubbelastung an der B96 zu messen oder irgendwas anderes zu machen, dann haben wir drüben das Rechenzentrum, in denen all diese Daten ihr Zuhause finden. Und wir das dann quasi auch noch alles verarbeiten können. Und der Teil, der jetzt fehlt, und das ist das, was im nächsten Jahr, also wir fangen im Herbst jetzt schon an, aber was vor allem 2021 dann passieren wird, ist, dass wir uns gerade fragen, wie schaffen wir eigentlich eine Infrastruktur, die quasi auch auf einer Netzebene irgendwie dann das komplementiert. Und wir sind jetzt gerade so ein bisschen im Gespräch mit der Stadt seit einiger Zeit wegen Zugang zu den kommunalen Dächern, Richtfunk, vielleicht die, wir haben so die Idee, dass wir einen Richtfunk-Backbone aufbauen wollen in der Stadt, um den dann als Grundlage zu nutzen, um quasi so Freifunkstyle ein freies WLAN für das gesamte Stadtgebiet auszurollen. Wir überlegen gerade, wie wir gemeinsam mit der Stadt oder auch unabhängig von der Stadt gewisse Glasfasertrassen verlegen könnten. Es gibt so ein paar Dinge, die nahe liegen. Wir möchten eben dieses Hermann-Lorra-Wahn, das gerade aufgebaut wird. Also sind so unterschiedliche Überlegungen, die in Richtung eines gemeinwohlorientierten Netzausbaus hier vor Ort gehen. Und auch das ist nicht zuletzt dieser ganzen Corona-Situation geschuldet. Also wir haben dadurch, dass wir ja sehr eng mit der Schule zusammenarbeiten, in den ersten Wochen, also wir haben so in der Corona-Zeit unterschiedliche Phasen gehabt. Unser Rechenzentrum ist gerade so in Betrieb gegangen, als das losging Anfang des Jahres. Dann haben wir ganz viel Big Blue Button-Infrastruktur ausgerollt, ein bisschen Moodle aufgesetzt für alle möglichen Schulen, mit denen wir so Kontakt hatten. Viele Nachbarschaftsinitiativen, also hier Krisenkultur, nebenan.de und so weiter, da sind auch einige Sachen, die hier bei uns irgendwie laufen. Die digitale Zivilgesellschaft, alle möglichen Dinge, die sich in dieser ganzen Situation auf einmal in Bewegung gesetzt haben. Da konnten wir total gut, hier sehr flexibel und kurzfristig sagen, wir haben hier Kapazitäten und schon hatte unser Rechenzentrum auch einen wirklich guten Daseinszweck, überregional, aber auch für die Region. Gleichzeitig haben wir uns ja überlegt, was ist jetzt mit der Schule? Ich habe dann irgendwann eine Schulung gemacht für die Lehrer hier an unserer Grundschule, wie sie das Big Blue Button benutzen können. Dann haben die ihr Leid geklagt, dass sie von so knapp irgendwas zwischen der Hälfte und zwei Drittel aller Schüler überhaupt nichts gehört haben, seit die zu Hause sind. Dann haben wir uns ein bisschen darüber unterhalten, wie sieht denn überhaupt, wie sehen die Kommunikationswege denn aus? Und was wissen wir eigentlich über die Situation bei den Kindern, was Geräte angeht, Internetzugänge und so weiter, damit die überhaupt aus dieser Webcloud des Landes Brandenburg, die für Schulen bereitgestellt wird, ihre Hausaufgaben runterladen können. Und dann haben wir so einen kleinen Umfragebogen ausgearbeitet, der von der Schule dann verteilt wurde an alle und haben festgestellt, dass das halt katastrophal ist. Und vor allem hat das niemand gedacht. Wir haben irgendwas zwischen 5 und 10 Prozent der Kinder haben Zugriff auf den Drucker. Jeder Lehrer hatte diese implizite Annahme, dass wenn die Arbeitsblätter per E-Mail verschicken, die Kinder sich das schon irgendwie ausdrucken können. Und ich glaube ganz oft ist die Lebensrealität einfach sehr unterschiedlich in ganz unterschiedlichen Familien. So und dann haben wir festgestellt, die wenigsten haben irgendwie einen Laptop. Und auch sehr wenige haben überhaupt Zugriff auf einen Laptop innerhalb der Familie, also vielleicht den von den Eltern oder so. Dann kam die Frage nach dem Internetanschluss. Die meisten, auch das war ein bisschen überraschend, aber eigentlich, wenn man länger drüber nachdenkt, dann auch logisch. Die meisten haben zu Hause keinen DSL-Anschluss. Das ist einfach viel zu teuer. Wir leben hier in einer strukturschwachen Region mit einem substanziellen Anteil an Sozialleistungsempfängern. Die haben halt ein Smartphone mit einer SIM-Karte drin. Und vielleicht haben auch die Kinder irgendwann ein Smartphone mit irgendeiner SIM-Karte drin. Aber keiner der Verträge, die die haben, ist dafür ausgelegt, vom Datenvolumen her, dass da jetzt Videokonferenzen gemacht werden und man den ganzen Tag vielleicht Lehrvideos gucken soll oder Arbeitsblätter runter lädt und hoch lädt und sich halt wirklich in einem ganz anderen Umfang im Internet bewegt. Das funktioniert halt gut, solange alle irgendwie nur WhatsApp machen. Aber das funktioniert halt nicht in dem Moment, wo man das braucht, als Grundlage zum Arbeiten. Dann sind, wenn das nur die Eltern sind, die das haben, die sind tagsüber arbeiten. Dann haben die Kinder in der Zeit, wo sie eigentlich für die Schule arbeiten sollten, nicht unbedingt ein Handy, das jetzt einen Hotspot aufmachen kann. Und selbst wenn man den aufmacht, dann ist halt unter Umständen nach einer oder zwei Wochen das Volumen aufgebraucht und es gibt das nächste Problem. Also haben wir festgestellt, da gibt es ohne Ende zu tun. Und der einzige Weg, wie wir dieses Thema adäquat adressieren können, ist, indem wir sagen, wir möchten, dass in Fürstenberg der Internetzugang Teil der Daseinsvorsorge ist. Und deswegen möchten wir dieses freie WLAN ausbauen, in Fürstenberg, aber auch in den Ortsteilen außenrum, dass einfach so eine Baseline gibt, wo niemand mehr ohne Zugang zum Internet sein muss. Und im besten Fall die Kinder, wenn sie nochmal zu Hause bleiben müssen, auch von zu Hause immer irgendwie lernen und arbeiten können. Wir haben 25 oder 30 Laptops, die wir verteilt haben an Kinder. Wir haben jetzt nochmal 40 weitere organisiert. Wir statten die alle mit so einem Standard Linux Image aus, wo so ein bisschen Software vorbereitet ist. Dann haben alle Kinder die gleiche Lernumgebung, arbeiten mit dem gleichen System. Wir können über Big Blue Button mit den Kids gemeinsam lernen, wie man mit dem Computer lernt. Wir machen jetzt gerade Lernen mit dem Computer zu lernen Kurse hier im Bahnhof. Demnächst auch noch ein bisschen Freiluft draußen. Da haben sich jetzt ein paar Schulen angemeldet, die mit Klassen vorbeikommen wollen, um quasi so ein bisschen unter diesem Schwerpunkt einen Tag hier zu verbringen. Falls die Schule nochmal geschlossen wird, was müssen die Kids eigentlich wissen, damit die besser klarkommen mit ihren digitalen Lernaufgaben? Und gleichzeitig ist das jetzt gerade total überraschend im Gespräch mit der Schule unter Umständen sogar eine Option für alles das, was im Rahmen des Digitalpacks angeschafft wird. Das wäre einfach sagen, wir setzen komplett auf freie Software. Und das ist so naheliegend, wie wahrscheinlich für viele von uns, irgendwie so ein insgeheimer Wunsch, den man ja hätte, der aber offensichtlich bei unserer aktuellen Schulleitung in der Grundschule sogar total auf offene Ohren stößt. Und das wäre natürlich auch absolut mega, wenn jetzt sowas noch funktionieren würde. Und so ist das einfach, im Endeffekt, dass es vielleicht das, auf was es hinausläuft, hier eine Spielwiese, auf der wir gerade Dinge ausprobieren können. Und dieser Infrastrukturteil, der gehört natürlich auch dazu.
Zum Schluss möchte ich von Daniel wissen, was er anderen Leuten raten würde, die ebenfalls in einer ländlichen Region einen Hackspace eröffnen möchten.
Also ich glaube, es gibt unterschiedliche Dinge, die wichtig sind. Und die sind wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen anders gewichtet, je nachdem, wie man so persönlich drauf ist. Aber als allererstes würde ich sagen, dass alle, die im Moment sich damit umtreiben, rauszuziehen, nach Fürstenberg kommen sollten. Also das ist definitiv nicht nur, weil es hier sehr schön ist, und weil ich glaube, dass wir gewisse Dinge vorangebracht haben, sondern im Besonderen, weil man hier nicht ganz bei Null anfängt. Und die ersten Jahre, die wir hier draußen waren, war der Kreis der Leute, die Sachen bewegen wollten, weil sie das als quasi einen neuen Standort für sich begriffen haben. Der war einfach wesentlich kleiner als heute. Und dementsprechend war es auch schwieriger, Dinge zu bewegen. Und wir sind heute an so einem Punkt, wo in den letzten Jahren wirklich substanziell schon Leute hergezogen sind. Und alle die Leute, die hierher kommen, eine andere Art von Gestaltungswillen mitbringen als Leute, die hier schon ihr ganzes Leben hier verbracht haben. Ich glaube, das liegt einfach in der Natur der Sache. Wenn man irgendwann irgendwo groß geworden ist, akzeptiert man viel eher, dass etwas ist, wie es ist. Während man als Neuzugang vielleicht andere Perspektiven mitbringt und auch eine ganz andere Motivation mitbringt, sich irgendwo einzubringen. Und wir sind im Moment hier in einer Situation, wo so eine kritische Masse da ist. Und man jetzt nicht ganz bei Null anfängt einfach. Wenn man sich irgendeinen der vielen anderen Orte auf dem Land aussucht, dann glaube ich, ist das Wichtigste, was man mitnehmen muss, Geduld. Also Geduld im Sinne davon, dass viele Dinge Zeit brauchen. Und das ist das, dass man Leute kennenlernt, dass man vielleicht, dass es Zeit braucht, dass man nicht empfunden wird als irgendein zugezogener Besserwisser oder jemand, der vielleicht verrückte Ideen hat, die erstmal alle bezweifeln, sondern man Zeit braucht, um zu beweisen, dass man an diesen Ideen auch festhält und die auf den Weg bringt und das irgendwie passiert. Und man darüber über Zeit sich eine andere Art von Glaubwürdigkeit verschafft. Das hatten wir hier auch. Am Anfang waren einige Leute so ein bisschen skeptisch. Was wollen die? Die machen so verrückte Computersachen. Hat das überhaupt irgendeine Relevanz für uns? Dann hat sich das aber über Zeit ergeben, dass die Leute festgestellt haben, warum das relevant ist, dass wir an den Sachen, die wir in den Raum gestellt haben, auch festhalten und das irgendwie sich manifestiert. Und diese Geduld braucht man, egal wohin man, glaube ich, geht. Und man sollte auf jeden Fall auch eine gehörige Portion Offenheit mitbringen. Also ich verstehe in meinem Metier vielleicht manche Dinge besser als die Leute hier. Aber es gibt tausend Dinge, die Leute hier besser wissen als ich. Und man muss, glaube ich, man darf nicht irgendwo auflaufen in dieser Vorstellung, dass man da jetzt hingeht, um alles besser zu machen oder so, sondern man muss sich einlassen auf eine Community, die ganz anders gestrickt ist, als das in der Stadt ist. Ich kann unendlich viel lernen von meinen Nachbarn. Und ich kann ganz andere Perspektiven entdecken, manchmal auch Perspektiven, die mir gar nicht gefallen. Ich kann auch Stereotype treffen, die mir nicht gefallen. Vorurteile gegenüber Zugezogenen, gegenüber Deutschen Zugezogenen, vielleicht genauso wie gegenüber Migranten, die hierher kommen. Und gleichzeitig kann ich feststellen, dass das wahrscheinlich in der Regel gar nicht ideologisch geprägt ist, sondern das damit zu tun hat, dass die Leute vielleicht nicht genug Exponierung hatten bisher. Und dann muss man einfach ein bisschen Geduld mitbringen und den Willen, sich davor irgendwie nicht zu verschließen, sondern das zu akzeptieren als Teil einer Gemengelage hier irgendwie. Und dann kommt man vielleicht ins Gespräch und dann stellt man fest, dass sich Dinge auch verändern. Also wir hatten hier so als ein total krasses Beispiel, als die ersten syrischen Familien hier angekommen sind und dann so die ersten Kinder in der Schule waren und sich Freundschaften ergeben haben und die ersten syrischen Kinder dann eingeladen waren auf Geburtstagen bei deutschen Kindern, hatten wir so einen Vater, der hier zu diesen ganz wenigen harten NPD-Leuten gehört, der hat seine Tochter abends auf den Geburtstag abgeholt und hat auch die syrischen Kinder nach Hause gefahren. Der empfand das als eine total normale Sache, die nach Hause zu bringen, weil das gar nicht in seinem Denkraum die Ausländer waren, mit denen er ein Problem hat. Das sind nur die, die mit seinen Kindern in die Schule gehen. Von denen weiß er, dass sie total nett sind. Dann sind das Leute, die sich in eine total gegensätzliche, widersprüchliche Gedankenwelt begeben. Aber der hat definitiv über seine erste Exponierung mit Leuten aus dem arabischen Raum festgestellt, dass sie gar nicht alle so sind, wie er sich das sein Leben lang vorgestellt hat. Diese Dinge brauchen Zeit und die funktionieren, glaube ich, auf dem Land viel besser als in der Stadt, weil sich nicht jeder hier einfach in diese Anonymität zurückziehen kann. Ich glaube, man muss diese Geduld irgendwie mitbringen. Geduld, um eigene Projekte aufzubauen und auch Geduld mit den anderen Leuten, die einfach alle anders drauf sind als man selbst. Weil man sich hier nicht in seiner Filterblase bewegen kann. Und das muss man auch, glaube ich, wissen vorher. Man kann nicht aufs Land ziehen und dann glauben, dass man genauso unter seinesgleichen ist, wie man das vielleicht in der Stadt ist.
Das war Chaos Radio Spezial, der Verstehbahnhof. Ein Hack und Make Space auf dem Land von Daniel Molkenthin. Es sprachen Christina Schavionke und der Autor. Eine Produktion des Chaos Computer Club Berlin.